[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont vêtus de noir et certains sont
masquées on les appelle les french lines
ceux qui sont en première ligne des
manifestations ces jours ci on les
retrouve dans leur appartement
léon et son ami qui se fait appeler john
nous montrent leur arsenal de
protestataires mask ha gazh lance-pierre
protection rigide
ils ne veulent pas qu'on montre leur
visage
ils craignent d'être arrêtés ils ont 23
ans
l'un est ingénieur l'autre est infirmier
il veille aussi aux premiers soins
pendant les manifestations
et tous deux insistent ils ne font que
se défendre
[Applaudissements]
trois mois après une gigantesque
manifestation pacifique pour dénoncer un
projet de loi autorisant les
extraditions vers la chine + mouvement
tente à se radicaliser prise du
parlement
occupation de l'aéroport qui a forcé
l'annulation de centaines de vols
affrontement avec la police plus de 700
personnes ont déjà été arrêtées
elle risque 10 ans de prison
michaud à 23 ans lui aussi et a étudié
en sciences politiques pour lui plus
question de reculer les manifestants au
même élargi leur demande
willis une épaisse au safran est le
status of kabila il n'y a pas que les
jeunes
même martin lee figure respectée du
mouvement pro-démocratie reconnaît que
des méthodes plus radicales
elles sont maintenant justifier de mon
passé au mali
on attend les principaux pays
disponible
mais la cheffe du gouvernement les
ignore
depuis la suspension du projet de loi
controversé car il amena rien concéder
sauf un début de discussion avec le
public
le sinologue français jean pierre
cabestan enseigne depuis 12 ans à
l'université baptiste de hong kong
on sent du côté du gouvernement une
absence de volonté de véritablement
négocier un accord de faire des
concessions qui aux yeux de pékin comme
aux yeux de carrie dame à mon sens ce
serait la porte ouverte à plus de
concessions à l'avenir et donc c'est un
pour éviter de se trouver sur cette
pente savonneuse que le gouvernement
reste inflexible
et c'est cette inflexibilité tout comme
la réponse très musclée des forces de
l'ordre qui ont renforcé la
détermination des plus radicaux mais
aussi choqué de nombreux hong kong
les images de cette femme qui s'est
interposé entre les forces de l'ordre et
les étudiants a été visionnée des
millions de fois et des cultures tina à
43 ans et elle est mère de deux enfants
revenu sur les lieux elle n'en revient
toujours pas hong kong n'est pas la
chine elle ne croyait jamais vivre de
tels événements ici trop détendus
mercredi
mais ce n'est pas tout dans cette ville
parmi les plus riches de la planète où
le coût de l'immobilier est astronomique
la colère des jeunes est aussi alimentée
par un manque de perspective
maintenant la situation est plus grave
que jamais pour nous on n'a pas tort
cottigny t2
acheter un appartement en khâgne peu et
on
veulent pas ça la vie des gens
pas vraiment terme
l'économie
auteur de l'argent mais en terme de
l'espoir l'imagination ou
l'amour etc la société on en a plus et
sonia montre du doigt l'immigration
chinoise du continent qui accroît la
pression sur toutes les ressources en
fasse beaucoup de compétitions qui vient
de chine
les étudiants chinois ils ont le droit
de rester à hong kong
on travaillait pour
gagner de l'argent
les opportunités
[Musique]
depuis la rétrocession en 1997
hong kong accueille chaque jour 150
nouveaux chinois c'est donc plus d'un
million deux cent mille personnes qui
ont eu le droit de s'installer et de
travailler alors que les jeunes hong
kong et à eux ont du mal à s'en sortir
[Musique]
depuis l'échec du mouvement des
parapluies en 2014 qui réclamait déjà
plus de démocratie
pékin a resserré son emprise sur hong
kong
alors aujourd'hui pour ces jeunes il y a
urgence s'ils veulent maintenir
l'identité les valeurs libérales de leur
ville avant qu'elle ne soit complètement
absorbé par le géant communiste chinois
sont habitués la liberté d'aller et
venir à la liberté d'association la
liberté de parole la liberté d'accéder à
tous les sites internet possibles et
imaginables liberté dont ils le sentent
évidemment immédiatement les limites dès
qu'ils se rendent en chine continentale
au cours de la fin de semaine les
affrontements ont repris entre
manifestants et policiers le policier a
même tiré au moins une fois avec une
arme à feu
est ce le début d'une escalade chacun
retient son souffle le convainc hong
hong et il ne peut pas reculer et pour
les jeunes
on ne peut elle pas elle
perdre parce que si on verse
cette fois ça sera encore plus grave
pour le futur de ce côté là